alright guys the day of the iPhone 6s
launched and puppy is not coming with us
we're gonna leave you here you don't
want to come I've got some pants on here
they're my emoji pants for the
celebration ok we go 6 a.m. I don't
think anybody's gonna be there I think
I'll be first line well the sun's not
out it's raining it's a really nice day
to go so the adults I don't wait for an
iPhone which is a good thing because I
don't think anybody else is gonna be
there and if they are they're crazy
which is basically saying I'm crazy well
there's nobody else here surprise the
middle of nowhere in North Carolina
first in line throw the phone is anybody
here yet open up I'm ready
iPhone 6s line forms here
ten minutes until the store opens
there's like five other people here
thanks mommy for bringing me
she's really excited this morning
we got it is we're doing our car
unboxing okay here we go
look at you
you look so shiny gold compared to the
silver and we'll have a rose gold
comparison as soon as I get home with my
sister Lilly I can't wait till we get
home turn over this thing this is
actually more rose gold
than the actual rose gold
hey Siri
hey Siri how's the weather today
hey Siri it's me
hey Siri is ready standard please next
baby looky look at the new phone oh my
finger than yours
oh yeah cos mines gold yeah I did but
guess what didn't have it got the only
one 28 rose gold Jenna would you make
you got the little teeny tiny baby one
though they depend minibuses
root no and then at all hold it I
dropped because I thought little bitty
baby huh well come over here let's take
a little peek at it no matches your skin
your pretty colors Oh baby look at you
[Music]
here's the rose gold which is pink so
one of the newest features is the force
touch so you'll be able to peek in as
they said you'll be able to create new
messages so you just press do to do it
and you can have the options to do
different types of actions so for
example on main camera you can press
harder and explain it you just push
harder than you normally would take a
photo record video take a selfie Apple
love selfies apparently so one of the
other things is the live photos so right
now I'm going to do a live photo and I'm
just gonna press the button and it's
recording the live photo
and that's it there's the live photos
and now here's a little 4k demo of the
new camera on the success hey show me
the 4k video I'm doing Wow real it looks
good oh say something I'm not prepared
for the camera not for 4k no we'll do it
back up look at my pants though here's a
little quick clip of the front-facing
camera which is now 1080p here's the
front-facing camera I just hearing a
little test to see what the audio sounds
like it's raining outside right now
which is really the great view that I
gave you guys here for the camera test
thank you guys so much for watching let
me know what you guys think of the new
success let me know what color you plan
on getting and if you don't have an
iPhone which phone do you guys have I'll
see you guys later
I'm gonna go come on go play with my new
phone in my puppy peace out my mom will
not let me go sleep outside the Apple
Store tomorrow mommy